good evening and welcome to the
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on the 18th of
november 2021
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i am the chairman of this committee
members the set up for this meeting is
designed to mitigate for covid therefore
can i ask all present to work to the
protocols agreed at council on the 2nd
of september 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak and then i will invite
you at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent upon the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask when not in when invited to
speak you remember to turn your
microphone on and turn it off when
finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
items please keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
members in addition to the offices in
the chamber there are three officers
attending remotely
finally can i draw your attentions to
the notices on the agenda papers
regarding the different levels within
the chamber and advise that fire exit
door is behind this top table
item two on the agenda apologies for
absence
maya have apologies for absence burner
thank you chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councillors
boyce and edwards thank you thank you
item three on the agenda is the minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 23rd of
september 2021 found on pages 5 to 12
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so
move do i have a second of that motion
you councillor jarvis if any member
wishes to raise any matter of accuracy
if not are you happy to accept those as
an accurate record
thank you
item 4 on the
agenda is declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other peculiar interests our
non-pecuniary interest relating to items
of business on the agenda
having regards to paragraph six to eight
the code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
councillor fleming
thank you chair um a non-pecuniary is a
member of essex county council any
matter that might arise thank you thank
you are there any other
declarations of interest no
lovely i will move on
item five public participation i can
advise that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
item six
is the internal audit report we move to
item six on the agenda found on pages 13
to 14. mr rubin's please present your
reports
thank you good evening um
with the chairman's permission i'm what
i'm going to do is um do this in two
blocks so the first block will be item
6a and 6b which are pages 15 to 32
of your pack
i'll take those items and any questions
and then move on to the three reports um
that we're presenting so um
the first of the two items i'm going to
present in the first block is the
progress report
it shows we've got as i say three
reports that have come coming to this
meeting and we're expecting to be a very
busy agenda for the february meeting
with probably six reports uh to present
there
and so quite a lot of work underway at
the moment
um and you also have within that
progress report a sector update which
obviously is more for information i
suspect most of these areas members are
already aware of but it's to obviously
make sure you are aware of them um and
then uh following that report we have
our our follow-up of previous
recommendations uh we've been able to
sign off um
two of the uh outstanding
recommendations but there are still some
outstanding particularly around flooding
and affordable housing what i would say
is if you look at the detail there
you'll see that some action is being
taken but they haven't yet got to the
stage where we can sign them off as
fully complete so obviously we need to
see that happen uh by the time of the
next meeting and i will be chasing that
out to ensure that it has
i'll stop there and as i say i'm happy
to take any questions on on that block
of work and then i'll go into the three
detailed reports and we can take
questions from there
counselor heard
thank you chairman and uh
just like to go to
page
16 please which talks about the summary
of work
um
on the
third paragraph which begins as a result
um
it speaks about uh the impact of kovid
19 and delays in delivery
um can i just can i just ask um
two things first of all something that's
that is mentioned is crm and it's got
customer service crm
i've looked through that i can't seem to
find what that actually stands for can
you help me there chairman
customer relationship management
i see okay that's fine
so so there is one part on there which
is customer service customer relation
management yeah okay that's fine so my
question is uh can i ask why why is
there a delay because of what the impact
has coveted had upon that because in my
experience with audit work
a lot of it doesn't have to be
physically there
um
why is there a delay please
you checked so a lot of bits to do with
um officer time and availability um at
the start uh obviously we had a full
full packed audit plan
um as if there wasn't a coveted pandemic
going on
but of course there was a covered
pandemic coming on which meant a lot of
the officers were actually addressing
that uh issue at the time you can
imagine back at the first of april the
start of the year still very much peaks
and lockdowns going on and actions taken
around
addressing the
health and safety risk as well as
business grants for example going out
and also the work the officers were
doing
around protecting the public and
safeguarding the offices as well so
that's meant a lot of delay to the
actual audits get started i'm quite
quite pleased to be honest that we've
actually started to catch up um that
work and the majority of the audits now
will be later in the year than preps
forecasts are actually now taking place
are being caught up so it's quite an
ambitious plan i would say in the midst
of a pandemic and tackling that but i
think it's good working and actually
trying to catch up on that plan
thank you if i could just come come back
thank you very much indeed for that but
uh so so the fault is not lying with the
auditors it's it's an internal uh issue
yeah yes that's right it's to do with
the staff availability to actually
assist with the audit and get that
carried out thank you very much
any other questions
mr rubins would you like to carry on
so as promised and we have three um
more detailed reports which i'll i'll
briefly go through so the first of um
the reports is on um
just go to the right page um
page 33
which is the covid recovery plan um so
um this was the plan that the council
has put together to
recover from covid and to develop a sort
of way of working a new way of working
uh to catch up uh from from from the
impact of kovid
and we've we've we're very positive
about this and we've given substantial
assurance on both the design of this and
the effectiveness
we think there's strong arrangements in
place a very clear plan
good um
good reporting good scrutiny of the plan
um and we were we were very happy with
it we've raised a minor point about the
terms of reference for the reset and
recovery group needing to be updated and
we've also done some benchmarking
against some other district councils
around their plans and actually again
the malden plan compares well to those
and it's kind of we've suggested you
know you might want to look at one
district which had managed to put all of
their plan on one page to make it a bit
more accessible and to the public but on
the whole as i say i think it's a very
good plan um and we're very positive
about about that area i'll move on just
go to the next report as i say i'll take
questions on the three reports at the
end uh so the next one is on
partnerships um so we've given moderate
assurance on this on the design and
effectiveness of controls
again i would say generally good
arrangements in place the council's
identified its partnerships as you'll
know is a good process for nominating
members to sit on partnerships um where
we've come up with some issues there's
three really one is around
distinguishing more clearly between the
two types of partnerships so your smart
partnerships the sort of strategic ones
and the formal partnerships which you
have to uh which have to be formed under
on the statutory basis so just making
the distinction clearer between those
two and what you need to do under each
circumstance um secondly was around
updating your thematic strategies and to
align with the update of the corporate
plan that has already been done i
understand
and thirdly is around
having more formal feedback from the
partnership process in terms of terms of
reference and minutes and so on and
again that's been accepted by officers
so
three recommendations there which um you
know we have been accepted and we will
follow up in due course and the last
report is the fraud risk assessment
this is not a standard internal audit
report it's an advisory piece of work
and
members who have been on this committee
sometime may remember there was original
recommendation for the council to
develop a fraud risk assessment which
we've assisted with and that's really
what this report is doing it's showing
you where the areas are that the council
needs to work on we haven't identified
any significant areas on the whole again
i think there's a lot of good controls
in place to um deal with fraud to
identify and deal with it and but there
are some areas there that we've um
suggested and for example more sort of
data reviews of procurement
and contracts um and um we've also
suggested um there should be more staff
documentation checks uh and also removal
of councillor signatures you might be
interested in this particularly i don't
believe that they're held and or haven't
been um held
for the last couple of years but there
were some historic ones on the on that
were available and obviously making sure
those aren't available to the public so
that they could use your signatures so
a few things like that that again the
council has accepted and there's an
action plan in place uh and i'm sure
again those will be followed through uh
in due course so on the whole i would
say for the three reports generally
fairly positive and some areas for
improvement but i'm happy to take any
questions okay is there any questions mr
rums councillor
jarvis
thank you chairman um yes i mean i'd
i'll go through them in order if i may i
mean as far as the kobe recovery plan is
concerned i think just need to give
recall congratulations to the council
clearly we've got its act together
substantially as your highest rating not
easier to achieve i don't think i've
seen one of those recently so i think
some congratulations to the officers
involved should be recorded
um just in sequence so well as far as
the partnership issue is concerned um i
think uh it is quite clear there are
there are that's moderate there are some
recommendations there the third of those
recommendations where it talks about uh
you know having minutes i think i would
emphasize that i i
i know a number of people here have been
elected to various bodies and then two
years later people didn't even know they
were on or they've never been to a
meeting nobody's ever seen any minutes i
realized the action point is clear the
council recognized that is a deficiency
but i think we'd all like to see that
improve so that we can get the most out
of those relationships so i think yes
there is there is work to do on that one
which you have quite rightly identified
as far as the uh the fraud
uh interim review or sort of some sort
of partial review that you've made not a
complete audit clearly the chart on page
75 uh i think is the most sort of a
clear pictorial representation of what
you think of where the council is with
fraud risk assessment in that sort of
heat map chart clearly showing there's
nothing nothing in the uh in the red
areas and just a few things in the amber
area so yeah well done again to the
council on that thank you very much
thank you is there any other questions
for
no
okay we'll go to the recommendations the
recommendations found on page 13 of the
report that the committee considers
comments and approves the
little one internal audit progress
report november 2021 at 6a
little two the follow-up of
recommendations report november 2021 at
6b
item little three the covid response
plan report october 2021 at 6 c
little for the partnership report
november 2021 at 60 and five
the fraud risk assessment audit report
november 2021 at 6 i a do i have a
seconder
thank you councillor jarvis
members are you all happy to accept
those recommendations
thank you
thank you thank you mr rubins you are
free to go now
item seven on the audit of accounts um
is going to be
mr rubins is about to leave so we'll
just give him a few minutes
thank you
thank you
item seven on the account is the update
of the audit of accounts we move to item
seven found on pages 81-86
mr leslie will you please present
reports
thank you
since the last statement of accounts
update public sector audit appointments
limited announced to just 9
of authorities had their accounts
audited by the 30th of september
coveted 19 and pressures in the audit
market were listed as some of the
contributing factors
in previous update in the previous
update it was reported that the audit of
the essex pension fund was not completed
which our auditors require for assurance
on our pension figures
the latest update from s expansion fund
is that their audit has been
significantly delayed and we do not have
an expected completion time at the
moment
the audit of our accounts has continued
and the auditors have subsequently
identified a classification issue with
some of the kobe grants which were new
for last year this relates to those
grants to businesses where the council
was passing money on from the government
without any discretion on the amount
these have been recognized as income
with matching expenditure in the income
and expenditure account which has a
needle impact on the bottom line as
income and expenditure matched
the little impact on the bottom line is
correct as the council was acting as an
intermediary or agent for these grants
they should not have been recognized in
the ine account however
the net financial position remains
unchanged as a result of this technical
classification and the amounts can be
extracted from the income and
expenditure figures to resolve this
however the auditors used the gross
expenditure figures to inform their
audit methodology and due to the high
value of the grants this has had a
significant impact on that
therefore they will need to revisit
their approach and conduct additional
testing which will impact on time and
audit fees
increased accounting complexities caused
by covered schemes were identified in
the last update report as well the
challenges faced during the closure
process and section 5 of the report
details many of the other challenges
that also presented themselves during
that time
revised figures have been given to the
auditors for them to revisit their
methodology
and we are currently working with them
to agree a revised timetable to complete
the audit
do i have any questions
from mr leslie councillor heard thank
councillor fleming
thank you jim page 81
please um or 82 rather
it's it carries on the the sentence from
it carries on the sentence from the
bottom of page 1981 which talks about uh
the value of the grants at 26 million
then over the page on 2082
it says the reduction this causes to the
auditor's materiality level towards the
end of the audit
i'm not quite sure what materiality
level is i wonder if you could help me
with that
um but my question is are we double
auditing because is this
26 million pounds already audited and
are we auditing again and if that is the
case are we suffering the cost from that
so in terms of the 26 million obviously
that is subject to uh checks uh
independently from um from government in
terms of uh their schemes where they've
given us money and they expect some
checks in place anyway however um that
doesn't form part of the actual external
audit who still need to check who's
going through the accounts correctly and
there's still the usual checks and
balances in place so it's not sort of an
additional or double audit if you if you
like they're very focused on uh perhaps
different areas with different
responsibilities um from that side but
yes obviously there's lots of checks
that do do go on
uh in regards to these things in terms
of the materiality i mean i've talked
about the mythology that the audience is
using materiality i i guess he is
perhaps one one of those levels that
sets a threshold for items that the
auditors are really interested in or
what they call that their materiality
level and they use that level to inform
some of the testing and some of the
reporting
which they do
because obviously now they're reducing
their materiality level
as well this which means some of those
things uh perhaps that they weren't
quite as
high up on the material scale now are
which means they're having a look at the
mythology behind that and conducts
potentially some more testing
okay thank you for that so it's sample
size really is it it could it could
include sample sizes okay as well
potentially thank you
councillor fleming
thank you chad a question for mr leslie
i'm not i'm not sure whether this agenda
item is is the best place to ask this
question i just when you were talking
about discretion over covered grants i
wanted to ask a question about the top
slicing of the arg
whether um you sort of have figures for
that
i was hoping maybe you could provide a
written response after the meeting sort
of
how much we top sliced and whether any
sort of cost-benefit analysis had been
done thank you
happy perhaps to produce a written
response um after the meeting if that's
okay thank you
is there any other questions councillor
jarvis yeah thank you very much chairman
um
yes i mean i think it is this does need
to be understood by councillors you know
is obviously very disappointing news and
this is likely to result in
certainly the auditor looking to
charge again for doing a lot of the
audit work
and uh obviously also putting the
pension issue to one side which may mean
the accounts would have been late anyway
um and that's not yet resolved but this
as i understand it although the
timetable hasn't been agreed it is
likely to be somewhere like at least
next february that's the sort of time
scale
so even if other councils get their
accounts done early because the pension
issue is resolved ours won't be done
early uh because um because because of
this the covert issue i think um we will
also have the challenging uh aspect of
the auditor wanting to charge us more
fees and this is on the back of
increased proposed fees anyway i'm
almost doubling of fees over the last
few years and the auditor has made it
clear
um that uh some of this extra work they
they see uh will be will be charged so
the cost
could be substantially more uh than
we've budgeted and i think you know i
think uh i i've made it clear that that
should be challenged in my opinion
because although it's true to say that
an auditor sort of comes in at the end
and assesses how a council has dealt
with something it's also true to say
that there is such a thing as a scoping
meeting early on in the process
during that scoping meeting the expenses
of this council were clearly identified
as being not marginally more but twice
as much correct if i'm wrong twice as
much as they normally are because of the
cave the way in kobe grants are going to
be treated
so this would have been clearly
explained to the auditor at the outset
at that time i would have thought that
it would have been reasonable in this
period of everybody getting covered
grass and the uncertainty of how they
were going to be dealt with it would be
reasonable to have suggested that rather
than set a high materiality level using
the additional expenses which is what
was done
options were given to the council would
you like to defer the audit until we
know how covered grants are going to be
dealt with
would you like to have a lower
materiality level in case the covet
grants are dealt with in a different way
but neither of those options were
presented or discussed instead what was
put on the table was no this is the
materiality level let's do a very high
level because of the double expenses
which is what that's based on let's do
checks at that level not that many but
based on that materiality and now we're
faced you know months later
the orchestra has come up with their
paper they produced a paper saying how
these uh how the expenses how sorry the
coveted grant should be dealt with
um but clearly over the over the past
six months this has been an issue which
the orders have been toying with as all
orders as we'd be toying with because
everybody's been receiving kobe grants
this isn't an issue just for our council
so i put it to members that i think
more should have been said earlier more
options should have been on the table
and we should resist any additional
charges that the order may wish to
lay upon us because don't forget our
officers will now in any case have to
carry out quite a lot of duplication of
work and so putting that to one side
that additional cost which i presume we
will just bet i think we should resist
very much any additional charge
that's uh put before us
thank you
councillor fleming thank you chad um
just i just wondered whether mr leslie
had an idea at this stage
how much more
it's likely to cost thank you
i don't have an idea at this stage we've
provided the auditors with updated
figures
and they're currently looking at how
that will impact their audit and what
steps they can take to sort of reduce
the impact of that but we don't have the
details at the moment
mr leslie can you um tell us when did
you do the scoping
meeting with the auditors when this was
first picked up
i believe the auditors presented um
their audit plan to the committee
i think in july time thank you
are there any other questions for mr
leslie
recommendations i found on page 81 of
the report the recommendation is that
report be considered do i have a
seconder
thank you councillor lemming
um
is everybody happy with that are you
like happy to vote with that on a saint
is it is it appropriate to we have got
the author
i think
yes i would would it would i'm sorry if
this is out of line no
i i i think it would be appropriate
perhaps for them to give us a short
statement of the position if you feel
that's
a merit this day
yes um
can't thank you councillor jarvis we can
do that tell you michael
um
mr
hewittson you are online would you like
to
give a short statement to the committee
as to why we find ourselves in this
position and
any questions they want to ask you
certainly chair um
included in the
pack of papers in appendix a to mr
leslie's report is our letter that
accompanies that that sets out the
a high level summary of the timeline
that has got us to where we are and the
issues that we've encountered and what
the
the scale and the nature of the problem
is
um
in terms of picking up some of the
questions that were posed by committee
members
um
into where we go from here yes the
final team have provided us with an
updated set of financial statements and
my team have been looking at those
in the last few days
and we estimate the materiality figure
has fallen as i've put in my sweet to
around 700 000 pounds a shade under
we've looked at the scope of our work
and
there are not only a number of areas
where the sample sizes will need to
increase as one of your members
suggested but also some areas where
testing that we've done
around analytical reviews
um
no longer fall within the expected
threshold the acceptable threshold and
they will also need to be revisited uh
one crumb of good news is that we have
not identified any fresh areas of
audit that need to be opened so it's
there was a worry that we might have
scoped some things out because they were
sufficiently small that we could and
we'd just have to scoop them in and
start those areas afresh
um the team we've done an exercise to
review that don't believe there are any
fresh areas of auditing it's just a case
of extending our work in the areas that
we've already been looking at or
refining our expectations where they
don't currently give us sufficient
assurance
um
i don't have an awful lot more to add to
mr leslie's
summary it was very complete
but i am happy to field any questions
from the committee members
okay thank you
committee have you got any questions for
mr
you
councillor jarvis thank you kevin oh
paul you don't mind uh could you just
comment with regards to um
uh potential additional charges you've
heard me say that i think the council
should robustly challenge those i mean
do you have an idea of what sort of
money we're talking about
at this stage council i'm afraid i don't
um as i said we and my team have been
going through the all at work to
understand how much additional work is
needed
to operate at the lower materiality
level
the next step as we agreed with your
finance team is to draw a project plan
uh to make sure we've got appropriate
results at the right skill level doing
the work at a time that's convenient to
you to minimize disruption
once we know what needs to be done
we'll then be in a better position to
understand what the total cost may be
and then we can start having a
conversation about that
so at the moment i realize this is not
entirely satisfactory but i can't give
you a clear answer that question at the
moment council trusts thank you just as
one supplementary chairman if i may with
regards to the sort of timetable in uh
vis-a-vis the sort of scoping and coming
up with this issue rather late in the
day do you do you accept in principle
that your firm will take that into
account when it's looking at raising
further charges against this council
because
negotiation is always one
that is based on
an open dialogue and a fair settlement
at the end of the day i don't
i never got into public sector auditing
in order to have the public sector's
eyes i've done it's not how i like to do
business it's not how i like to behave
um
but we do need to agree a fair fee so
i expect there will be a robust
negotiation between the finance team and
our team once we know what the number is
and i'm sure all issues will be brought
to the table
if it is the case that we cannot reach a
mutually agreeable settlement
then the ultimate arbitration is through
the psaa who must agree all audit fee
variations anyway and they will give the
council the opportunity put their case
forward if they feel it's not been
appropriately taken into account
thank you very much thank you chairman
for that thank you for that
clarification appreciate it
are there any more questions
no
thank you very much for uh briefing the
uh chamber
so back to the recommendation that's
found on page 81 of the report and that
to the report to be considered i had a
second which was councillor fleming are
you all happy to accept that
recommendations
thank you
council uh item eight on the agenda is
the report for the decision to opt into
the national audit uh scheme for
auditors appointments we move to item a
found on
to
pages
mr leslie will you please represent that
report thank you
in december 2016 the council agreed to
opt in to the national audit appointment
arrangements established by the public
sector audit appointments
psaa
for the period covering the accounts up
to in and including 2022 to 2023
procurement is now underway for the next
period
the council has three options in this
regard as detailed in paragraph 3.2
to arrange their own procurement
and make the appointment themselves
to do so in conjunction with other
bodies
or
we can join the national scheme
paragraph 3.4
details the requirements to make the
appointment directly or with another
body
this would require the council to
establish an independent auditor panel
the majority of which could not be
counselors or past counsellors or their
close family or friends
the audit panel would need to make the
appointment and manage the contract for
the duration of the audit term
the recommendation is to opt into the
national scheme on the basis it would
provide economic scale
expertise and avoid the resource
required and risk of operating an
independent auditor panel
in the last appointing period
only 9 out of 485
qualifying authorities
opted out of the national scheme
with two of those later opting back in
thank you mr leslie do i have any
questions for mr leslie
councillor fleming
thank you chair i wanted to ask mr
leslie
do you know which councils the nine are
and and do you have any sort of
information as to were they
were they able to negotiate better fees
thank you
i do know three of the seven which were
left
outside of the scheme
they are actually in essex police fire
and crime commissioner the police and
essex
fire
as well
um other they i believe are very happy
uh with the arrangements that they've
made um opting out um and the feedback
i've had very satisfied with the
arrangements that they have in place
councillor jarvis uh and thank you
chairman i mean i will in a moment be
very happy to sort of second this
because i think councillors should be
aware as they've heard the stats very
few people opt out there's a reason very
few people opt out because if you opt
out you have to actually go through a
whole process which is quite expensive
so you know sometimes when you're
dealing with an auditor that you've been
given you think to yourselves well i'd
like to pick my own one you know perhaps
i do better but the answer is you won't
and the reason you went is because it
will cost you a lot more money to set up
all the infrastructure the office of
time in actually
appointing one yourself and that may you
may not do a better job obviously in a
pointed one it will certainly probably
cost you more money the other thing is
um i have fortunately been able to speak
to the officers at uh the national
school for disappointments they're a
professional bunch of people and they've
done all of this before and if you
wanted anybody to be negotiating and
acting as an arbitrator on your behalf
they're the sort of people you'd want so
for me i have absolutely no hesitation
at the moment hopefully in seconding up
this recommendation but
i understand if some counselors might
think wouldn't it be good to do it
ourselves but the bottom line is in my
opinion it wouldn't be
thank you councillor charles
uh mr hewitts and you wanted to come in
you've got your hand up
yes it was just an odd um
content i know three of the local
authorities local to me uh went outside
the psaa contract and just by way of a
cautionary tale they did fall out with
their auditor who resigned
and left them struggling to find
somebody to pick up their audits because
they weren't in
the past they didn't have to save the
psaa arrangement around them
to
effectively
require somebody to undertake their
order so just further context but
committee's consideration
thank you very much
is there any more questions for mr
leslie
no thank you
the recommendations are found on page 87
of the report the recommendation to the
council little one is that the council
accepts the public sector audit
appointments invitation to opt into the
sector-led option for the appointment of
external auditors to principal local
government and police bodies for five
years from the 1st of april 2023
do i have
thank you councillor jarvis
is everybody happy to accept those
recommendations
thank you
yeah if the auditors would like to leave
they are welcome to
exit thank you for
joining us at this meeting
thank you
item nine on the agenda is the section
one 106 six monthly update and
infrastructure funding statement we move
towards a gender item nine found on
pages 101 to 112. mr dobson would you
please present the report
thank you chairman mrs oltof shawland is
present on teams to present this report
for us thank you
hello
um but yeah i'm going to
present this report that was written by
stephen andrews who's currently off sick
and so i've stepped in to do this for
him tonight
um the report covers the sixth monthly
update in respect to section 106's
um it also asks for approval to publish
on the council's website the annual
infrastructure funding statement
for the year 2020 to 2021
very broadly
since the last reports committee in june
the council's received payments from
developers of just under 140 000 pounds
to go towards health facilities and
youth facilities in burma crouch
also since the last report the council
has paid out eight thousand pounds
towards allotments in burnham
and fifty thousand pounds of the essex
wildlife trust for works at the blue
house farm nature reserve
um additionally since the last report
the council secured 11 affordable houses
nine affordable rent and two for shared
ownership
with regard to the infrastructure
funding statement
this covers the period april 2020 to
march 2021
so it's a slightly different period to
the um report that we've just covered
um it's a mandatory requirement and for
the council we have to do this and we
have we should be publishing this
statement on our website by the 31st of
december each year
so during the 12-month period covered by
the
infrastructure funding statement
requests for payments and generated into
the council 121
620 pounds
there were no payments out during the
period
and section 106 has delivered 150
affordable homes
that's 116 affordable rented and 34
shared ownership homes
thank you
is there any questions
councillor jarvis oh thank you very much
chairman um i've got one question it's
really just for members information
because it is a point you'll be aware
chairman we did raise at the agenda
meeting with the officer
which is that on on section 4.3
so that's page 102
it does refer to how much has been
received and how much how much that is
of a total sub 45 hasn't been perceived
140 has and i think what i what i'd like
to ask what i have already asked for
what we'd like to see in the future
uh is um some sort of performance clear
performance evidence um so that sort of
statistics put into some sort of chart
so that over a period of time we can
understand in simple terms how effective
are we in in getting the money from the
106 agreements and i think some sort of
chart would be fairly easy to put
together i'm going to see if we're
getting better or worse as far as that
particular performance aspect is
concerned
i have mentioned this already as you
know chairman but i'm mentioning it for
the benefit of other councillors that is
something i've requested and it's
something that the uh um uh that the
person who normally would deliver this
report
embarrassing i've forgotten is said
he'll do
thank you
and you want to come back
um yes i'll just go say it might be an
idea to arrange um
a quite short workshop with the members
of the committee just to go over exactly
uh a bit of a refresh about what section
106s are and how we can report this more
effectively you know how members would
like to see this because there is lots
of information that sits behind these
reports that perhaps we can draw out
more effectively for members okay
members would you like a short workshop
for this 106.
yes and that
all members are in agreement of that
counselor keys i'll come to you after
councillor fleming
councillor fleming did have a hand
first
thank you chair um i just wanted to ask
um i don't know whether this is for and
possibly uh mr dodson um the report
references the infrastructure
implementation group i was uh interested
to find out who who sits on that and
what member oversight there is for that
thank you
and
uh it's a variety of officers
across the council who who would have
some kind of um
role to play in implement implementing
the spend on the infrastructure
so um
somebody from
um
the community the team that does the um
communities parks and gardens and things
like that they they sit on it and john
swords for affordable housing matt lee
sits on it i sit on it
um
paul dodson sits on it there's a
strategic group and a delivery group
as far as i'm aware i don't think there
is any member oversight we don't have
any members
um sitting on any either of those two
groups
the reports actually come to this
committee about section 106's
thank you mr dobson
thank you chairman it's just to
reiterate it's an operational group
about making sure that the work goes on
behind the
scenes to
um monitor what's happening and make
sure we're delivering on any section 106
that that comes to the council itself
and um just to reiterate what um this is
although shawlin said
the the the member oversight is very
much through this committee
that's
where the the results of those those
meetings come to and it's to inform the
work that comes here thanks okay i'll go
let you come back and then i'll get
councillor jarvis councillor hull
councillor stevenson councillor herd
sorry councilman councillors
yeah councillor keys
so i'll let you come back first thank
you chair um i'm i'm not so i'm not
concerned so much now that we have the
two
new officers in the policy team about
collection of um 106 developer
contributions i think that we've
actually made great strides in that area
in the last year and i'm very pleased
that they're with us
um
i think my concern is is the delivery is
getting it out the door and and planning
and and delivering it for our residents
um
i know that we all know the issues with
the gps across malden
um i don't want to sound like a stock
record but
um
i think that's my concern is the
delivery
is
is not moving as fast as it could thank
you mr dobson do you want to come back
yes thank you chairman um we have
internally with the section 106 that
comes to us we have a program approach
and we've extended that to
all of the section 106 funding so
in effect i think some some of the
information that um officers would share
at the workshop is that we have a clear
program schedule of
all of the money when it comes in
when it's due to be spent and the
projects that it's it relates to
and ultimately when the backstop is
because if if things aren't delivered
there's a there's a clawback date on um
some of that section 106 funding so as
well as we put that in place internally
for all of the projects we were
delivering we've then worked with
partners and obviously we're dependent
on partners be it the nhs essex county
council to deliver infrastructure that
they are the statutory authority for so
we have all of that information as well
within those program plans and we do
regular reviews with them to try to
ensure that that they're spending it on
time but we are still
to an extent in their hands on the
delivery of that although we do monitor
it and we do work proactively with them
to encourage the prompt delivery of
those infrastructure items thank you
councillor keys
thank you very much i'm just i'm
interested just there's 11 affordable
homes secured through the sl
106 still in sites comprised of nine
affordable rented and two shared
ownership are they in malden or burnham
where's the majority of them do we know
just purely through
is that a question for you mr geller
okay if you could respond to that in
writing that would be lovely
council hull
oh thank you um i i heard about the
youth um what the 106 money going to the
youth in burnham on crouch um could you
tell me more about
how you'd go about finding out what you
want with that money is that true
except for would that come up in the
workshop um
i'm not sure
would that be better coming up in your
workshop for members
it can do i can um
i can i can email the answer if you want
yes that's lovely
yeah that'd be great thank you that
would be lovely thank you
councillor stevens
thank you chair coming back to this 45
000 that's awaiting payments and we've
we've sort of walked around it a bit but
i think you know it's a quarter of the
amount and i think i'd like to know is
that
a grave risk of never coming forward or
is it um actions all in hand
it's expected next week how dangerous is
it this 45 missing thousand
thank you
and do you want to answer that
um
can i just clarify what the question is
question is was it how
how sure are we that the money that is
not
that hasn't come forward yet is going to
come forward was that was that the nub
of the question yes that's right thank
you
yeah well
section 106s have triggers
so um once the development starts and
the triggers start to be met then the
developer has to has to pay them and
there are consequences if they don't
developers do pay them once the triggers
are met but the triggers are normally
staged
so you'll get maybe a payment after so
many houses are completed and then
another payment and then a payment at
the end so that's why the money seems to
trickle in really because because of the
triggers but what as i said once the
development started
then the money is going to come in we're
pretty sure the money's going to come in
it's if the development doesn't come
forward that then then of course then
there is no funding to come forward
thank you
councillor heard
um thank you chairman actually i think
councillor stevens has almost uh got got
my point but the the question i would
ask is is that 45 780
overdue i appreciate we're awaiting it
is it overdue or is it something that
will come to us
please
um if
well the development must have started
so if it started it will come to us when
the triggers are met
um
sometimes it does take a long time for
the triggers to be met because the
triggers might actually be money coming
in at the end of the process
um
in the workshop we can go into triggers
in a little bit more detail and we can
go into individual
pieces of infrastructure in a little bit
more detail
could i just come come back because i
think i think if
if we're being told that that 46 000
pounds is is still awaiting
i think i'd like to know whether it's
overdue or whether those triggers have
been met
because it's one thing to await it it's
quite another if we're waiting for a
late payment
so is that something that can be
established
please
as far as i'm aware we're up to date
with all of our
requests for payments so
triggers
if money hasn't come in it means
triggers hasn't been met or we put out a
request for payment and the money hasn't
come in yet
thank you and one more question is i i
see that uh i i think i'd be perhaps
cocker hoop if i was
in burnham but is there any money
forthcoming for other areas of the
district
well we can we can send you i can send
you more details by
email or we can go through it at the
workshop in more detail
thank you councillor jarvis and then
councillor fleming uh thank you chairman
sorry without wishing to sort of harp on
this point um perhaps you could uh
mention to uh officer andrews um that i
think it she it would easily should
easily be made clear um this is the
amount due
this is the amount we've received um of
the total amount due this is the amount
that's triggered that we haven't got yet
or this is the amount of bad data you
know i think the uh the phrasing in the
paragraph is ambiguous we don't know if
it's outstanding or not we don't really
know if it should have come in through a
trigger so i think back to my sort of
point about the sort of clear statistics
perhaps so when that is looked at
preventing performance statistics we
could be a bit clearer in the narrative
in the report uh because councillors
quite rightly uh are saying it's not
clear what a weighting means so i think
a little bit of work on that of course
that can come up in the workshop as well
but i think when we're presented with
figures we want to know if we should be
worried or not and i don't i think at
the moment we're unsure of whether we
should be worried or not that's not a
good state of affairs thank you
councillor fleming
thank you chair um the report references
the uh essex county council
infrastructure funding statement i
wondered whether officers
when that is published presumably at the
end of the year as well whether it would
uh they could circulate that to members
uh so that they have that for their
information
um and then also my other question
which might be for mr leslie actually
i'm looking at page page 109
table 2.3
there's health uh balance held
march end of march
2021 455
000 for health
can i just understand it correctly is is
that we we spend that on health or or
the nhs or the ccg
it's sitting in our coffers who who
actually spends that money thank you
thank you
also um
ask and just to confirm as well but
i believe this table sets out how much
we've received some receipts so it
should be amount sitting in our balance
sheet for us to spend in accordance with
those um agreements
um
we
health will have a project the nhs
will have a project they will then ask
us for the money and then we remit it to
them
are you happy with that
yes thank you so um just question four
and so
deliveries is actually down to the nhs
then you're waiting for them to
to put together a
a project for you
yes but it must be within the terms of
the section 106 but yes so it has to be
site-specific
yes it depends on the terms of the
section 106. i think most of them are
area
specific
area okay thank you
thank you are there any other questions
counselor hull
um
there's 106 money that they said you
said just coming to burn and i'd like to
point out that blue house farm is
actually in banbridge it's not in
burnham
but is it the 106 money is that from
burnham all the houses that are going up
there
is it is it from oil from everywhere
else
can you turn yeah my counselor fleming
can you
i can answer that i think um cancer hull
it's from there was a development of
roughly 100 homes in north banbridge so
so i would think it would be related to
that
thank you
maybe uh miss
hook this is hulk shotland couldn't find
that information and
yeah because we've had a lot of houses
in burnham and if it's all going out of
burnham but also coming back to the nhs
southminster have been waiting they've
got the housing
um at the fish's way and we're still
waiting for the nhs and that's been
waiting for a long time and southwest
are desperate for a bigger
um doctor's surgery and that was brought
up been built up every time since
so i don't know what's happening there i
think um mr dobson wants to come in on
that one
just on on the southminster
health
center
we do regularly meet with the nhs to
ensure that that's going forward and i
confirm that the the business case is
progressing through the nhs
and we're regularly monitoring where
they are in terms of of
progressing that to ensure that it is
delivered
do we know how far they've got because
this has been like quite a few years now
hasn't it
i understand that they've passed the
outline business case and are finalizing
um
the full business case subject and then
then a planning application will come in
they not already got the plan in
is it is it does it not come on with the
housing
outline they need to put in
they need to put in a planning
application for the to develop it
can you turn your microphone off when
you're doing this
you can turn it back on if you're gonna
it's just it's been going on a long time
and we just wondered you know
the people in south midst do need they
haven't got
they're very tight for space in there
and they have more and more houses and
most people in south america can't get a
doctor
maybe um if mr dobson can find out
how that's going on and then email
the members to let them know where we
are with that
thank you
um thank you uh this is
hulk shotland um
for your presentation
members
sorry counselor heard well i i i only
feel it right that i think that it
wouldn't be confined to southminster i
think everywhere um is uh is very short
of
medical staff so i certainly wouldn't
want it limited to southminster but if
mr dobson can go away and find out some
more information that'll be lovely
they have been this has been going on a
long long time and it's just that their
surgery isn't very big to get doctors in
so they
the recommendations are found on page
101 of the report
little one that the committee considers
the six monthly update on section 106
planning obligations
little two that the committee approves
the malden district council
infrastructure funding statement 2020 to
2021 for publication and government
submission
asset
as set out in appendix one do i have a
seconder
thank you councillor jarvis is everybody
happy to accept those recommendations
thank you
item
10 on the agenda is a report process
improvement framework we move to item 10
found on pages 113-126
mr dobson would you please present
it cheryl is it oh miss hughes would you
like to present the report
uh good evening members
the process improvement framework is a
document that outlines our approach to
continual improvement work at malden
district council and it's provided as an
appendix to this report
process improvement is work that was
already kicked off as part of 2019
council transformation and current
activity is part of our existing
staffing structure so it's brought to
the committee for context and feedback
rather than a request to do anything new
it is an important part of our wider
approach around how we address
performance issues and how we implement
processes that are identified as part of
internal audits
in the summary of key issues section of
the header report we also highlight how
this work fits with wider corporate
requirements and organizational learning
over the last few years
process improvement is crucial work to
support the value for money criteria of
molden as a local authority and
throughout the framework at appendix a
we have also highlighted how the work
supports wider corporate objectives such
as those set out in the ict policy
page 121 of the report pack also
highlights some case studies of the type
of work that the team carry out and page
122 onwards sets out future plans and
work of the team as well as potential
risks to delivery and what our
mitigations are
in the header report you will see that
there are two recommendations
the first
the committee reviews and feeds back on
the framework
and the second is around committee
appointing member representatives
we're seeking member
nominations to work closely with the
team as we develop processes to help add
a layer of customer feedback and to help
input into future process improvements
we're recommending two appointments from
performance governance and audit
committee with a further two to be
recommended from overview and scrutiny
committee at their next meeting
thank you
thank you miss hughes
i have had two members that have come
forward
and shown an interest in being the
representatives from this committee and
that was councillor stevens and
councillor fleming
are we happy to
agree that those are our two
representatives
thank you
so the recommendation oh sorry has
anybody got any questions
for miss hughes
counselor
stevens
thank you chair um i don't know if it's
really a question it's a statement
really i see on page 122 that one of our
achievements is to remove the pink sac
collections at malden district council
office
um
well that's probably happened because of
covid anyway um but i imagine it perhaps
happened before that i've got to say
that i don't see that as an achievement
at all if i lived just next door to the
council office and i came in here and i
just wanted to pick up a roll of pink
sacks and walk out again
that really wouldn't or certainly
shouldn't take anybody very long to
serve me and if i've got poor mobility
and i can't do that i've now got to walk
half a mile to the nearest shop or get
in my car um i just don't see that as an
improvement and i wanted to say that
thank you thank you
councillor jarvis
just picking up on that point i think if
you're a member of that group going
forward you'd be able to make that
comment would you yeah i think i just
wanted to say chairman i think i mean
it's clearly a very good idea i mean
that you you can't fault the approach
it's clearly going to
look where value can be added um my
question is uh just confirmation that
there's no additional cost involved
from the council my understanding is
that there isn't and this is just a
reorganization of how things are done
with existing staff okay mr leslie
yes that's right just lays out the
process that the existing team are
taking and so the work um that they do
the good work that they do to actually
improve things we in fact um we relies
on a previous um growth bid around the
process improvement work and this just
continues on so there's no additional
resource um going in other than that
it's already ready agreed
thank you for
thank you for giving us that
confirmation it clearly seems to me to
be an excellent piece of work which we
um we should um applaud and support
thank you
councillor hood
um thank you chairman uh i i think um
although it might not be an achievement
to have the removal of pink sac
collections i i quite understand it but
actually this is this is more of
introducing a network of other places
where it can be collected so i know that
it can be collected i know that i can
get bags from my local paper shop from
the town hall and from some garages as
well so i see that actually as an
improvement yes we can't get them from
here
i know that when they were originally
placed they simply got taken on mess
just stolen
so i don't i don't really think that
that was an ideal situation but i am
seeing other networked places
distributing these sacks which i do see
as an improvement but
thank you
is there any other questions
no
the recommendations are found on page
113 of the report little one that the
committee reviews the feedback on the
process improvement frameworks are at an
appendix a little too that the committee
appoints two member representatives and
seeks to representatives from overview
and scrutiny committee
at his next scheduled meeting to work
closely with the team around the website
testing at
customer feedback
do i have a second
thank you are members happy to accept
those recommendations
thank you
item 11 on the agenda is any other items
of business that the chairman decides
are urgent there are none
item 12 is the closure of the meeting
members thank you for your contributions
this evening i now draw the meeting
closed at 20 35
as the meeting is now closed
you